spiritualität buddhistische tradition
seiner vorväter
das ist dem tibeter tenzin wichtig auch
in der schweiz 2013 floh er hierher aus
seiner heimat gründete eine familie
ich möchte hier in der schweiz bleiben
und als fähige ssd arbeitet und vor
meine familie arbeiten und ihr ein
normales leben zu leben
in diesem dorf bleiben sich eine neue
existenz aufbauen
davon träumt es in seinen richtigen
namen haben wir verändert auch seine
frau floh in die alpenrepublik
sie haben alle brücken in die alte
heimat abgebrochen rufen die man aus
angst ich habe keinen kontakt mit meiner
familie weil ich ihnen keine probleme
marken will meint e-mail wusste auch
nicht dass sie zwei kinder habe dass das
ist sehr traurig für mich und habe ich
auch seerhein b an eine rückkehr nati
wird ist nicht zu denken
drei asylanträge haben die schweizer
behörden abgelehnt weil sie glauben dass
templin über ein sicheres drittland
hierher kam ohne papiere dürfen sie aber
nicht arbeiten obwohl er ein praktikum
als altenpfleger gemacht hat bei
behördengängen helfen freunde die sie in
der schweiz gefunden haben wir versuchen
dann von den tibeter organisationen her
sie zu unterstützen ihnen zu helfen zum
beispiel mit dem paten netz um ihnen den
haupttag etwas leichter zu machen
trost und stühle fürs gebet viele
tibeter finden es hier in einem
buddhistischen kloster eine autostunde
nördlich von zürich auch tänze liebt
diesen ort er erinnert ihn an seine
jugend die habe in einem kloster
verbracht daran denkt er gerne zurück
alles schön für morgen aufstehen und ins
bett
[Musik]
das unbeschwerte leben endete als
chinesische sicherheitskräfte die mönche
drangsalierten sie versuchten sich
dagegen zu wehren
vergebens jeden tag stören sie uns und
unter druck ist sie uns unsere freiheit
dagegen habe ich also bleibt plakat
geklebt und proteste gemach freunde
sollen gewarnt haben die polizei sei auf
der suche nach ihm
denn sinn floh in die schweiz der abt
des klosters wenn viele ähnliche
schicksale nordpol reich im grunde gibt
es keine religionsfreiheit in china
wenn du die regierung kritisiert werfen
sie dich ins gefängnis
ein agent der kopf von max mosley gehen
darüber reden wollten wie auch mit
jemandem von der chinesischen botschaft
in bern
doch unsere interview anfragen blieben
unbeantwortet
in die schwarz geflohene tibeter für die
chinesischen kommunisten sind das
oppositionelle
china setzt in den beziehungen zur
schweiz ganz auf den ausbau der
ökonomischen beziehungen beider länder
verbindet seit 2013 ein
freihandelsabkommen der handel wächst
kontinuierlich wirtschaftsinteressen zu
verfolgen und dabei demokratie und
menschenrechte zu verteidigen
ein balance-akt für die schweiz china
tritt zunehmend autoritär auf seine
interessen stärker durch in der
wirtschaftspolitik in der
flüchtlingspolitik und darauf muss die
schweiz auch reagieren und koordiniert
hervorgehen in die chinesische botschaft
mussten sind vor einiger zeit wollte
sich bestätigen lassen dass er aus liebe
stammte
die sandbox gegangen einen ausweis zu
holen
und viele haben angefangen nicht zu
streiten und es bilde mich bedroht die
chinesen weigerten sich im
entsprechenden papiere zu geben nach wie
vor fühlt er sich bedroht
schließlich haben ihm die schweizer
behörden bislang kein asyl gewährt wie
es weitergehen soll
er weiß es nicht